what do you think is the most
misconstrued thing about the red pill
why does it get such a bad rap
uh it's the truth right so again people
want to live in fantasy so if I tell you
if I tell you things like romance is a
myth
who wants to hear that's you
if I say romance is a myth
um that's toxic to a lot of people
and if I'm telling men you don't need to
that that was meant for you essentially
that's going to be equivalent to
pornography for me like that's what I
make it and then men can get an
understanding yeah that's fake you know
but yeah that's why people people don't
want to live in that type of world I
think they don't know what to do with
themselves after that
most people are useless
in the world they're they're useless
they have to be told what to do every
day they got told be told when to wake
up
uh they're gonna tell one time to go to
Street uh sleep what type of your sports
team is playing uh what to do at work on
a daily basis most people need guidance
on a daily basis uh in essence you're
useless so in essence then if you're if
you're useless I got to tell you what to
do and how to make love and
and how to treat a woman and all that
stuff you know the guys your guys you
went to high school with that boned all
the hot cheerleaders and the chicks that
guy right there he's been living in this
truth
he's discovered a truth that men don't
discover until age 30 and 40 if at all
that all women are the same
okay
he's experienced it most men at 18 ain't
experience nothing right it so it takes
him up to age 30 35 40 sometimes 50 55
to be able to have five women to go oh
it was all the same the dude that 16 17
18 running through them he's in college
running through them he like these girls
ain't it one's differently
you don't think any girls are different
what do you mean but they're all the
same in terms of what you're what you're
getting from them the whole
transactional term of it right so some
girl is going to be like I'm special I
know my worth right she's gonna say all
that [ __ ] right and then you're gonna
take a route it's gonna be a dudge
you're gonna lay there on bed like a
damn Carl's Jr star like a dead fish and
you like
that ain't nothing right yeah yeah so we
have this idea that women are special
and they they increase in value over
time you know what I mean and she knows
meaning like I know my words so she
raises the value she raises the price as
you get older stop at the born-again
Virgin yeah that's enough yeah yeah
three packs
so when Chad was [ __ ] you like you
didn't give a [ __ ] about God
yeah the born again the morning
yeah those are the to me to me I know
that these people are worthless because
I've gotten them not worthless but there
don't have the value they perceive let's
just put it like that because I know
people got hurt feelings now they don't
have a value they perceive themselves to
have so what's going to happen is these
people are going to learn over time that
people don't see them as valuable then
what
they're gonna be out here still talking
about they know they were 40 45 50.
nobody nobody's gonna take that dude
what do you so since you're you're 47.
so you have a bit more life experience
than me a little bit a little bit
you'll catch up fast ladies 40s right
around the corner don't act like I'm old
if you're 25 40 is in 15 years I want
you to think about that
it's 15 years along I guess when I was
25 you're like 15 years was a long-ass
time that [ __ ] happened yeah I was 10 15
years ago so you like that's a long ass
yeah 25. and then you're here
okay well so
yeah that was it I know I know yeah yeah
yeah yeah so my question was
um
what do you like what happens to the
like what what happens to like the girls
that sleep around and like do they ever
get married do they end up getting
married some of them do some of them
some of them would you say most two or
most just die alone uh you die alone
yeah they they don't die alone yet 40 is
not death yeah but what typically
happens is most of them become left over
right most of them just go on the [ __ ]
Carousel and have their fun and then
they use relationships as a break from
the [ __ ] Carousel and they'll fall in
love and they'll post that person on
Facebook and Instagram you know but like
I finally found a step daddy for my son
and daughter and then they'll break up
they'll delete all the pictures that
[ __ ] is a vicious cycle right then by
the time they hit 40 and 44 they like uh
I'm living my best life and they'll be
they'll have money they'll have a good
job
and they'll have a Mercedes C-Class
Mercedes and they'll they'll be balling
out of control they'll ball out till
they fall out then 50 hits
then they are done
it's a disaster by then it's a disaster
what they're going to hope now is that
some dudes gonna take that deal if they
ride it out to that most guys and this
sometimes happen mid-40s it just depends
most guys don't take that deal
and they just a single old woman
the problem is they say men are in the
same boat and that's not true
at the men aren't that men are at their
Peak
men are like going skyrocketing and
that's the dynamic they banked on men
being still the losers that they were
when they were 30. all these guys I'll
just settle down with these guys but by
40 between 35 and 55 for men is like
Super Bowl
we winning
we got choice now or at least like what
fine wine yeah well in essence our big
head out thinks a little head
or we've been manipulated or we've been
burned right or we've been finessed so
now we're like oh we see what y'all
doing and then women in our state age
group they still trying to run the same
Playbook
be like we know what that [ __ ] is like
don't try to run that [ __ ] on us that
ain't gonna work and then they wonder
why men why aren't these men committing
to you I could go down to the junior
college
and I could have me some fun all right
with a younger woman
that's that that's the junior college oh
okay yeah yeah okay okay okay
I'm learning so many terms today yeah
yeah
I'll say that when people come on my
shell be like you're at the junior
college you're in the junior college age
range yes yes yes and and typically
older men we get the junior college
girls under the cover at night we send
them back to the dorm after we're done
with them
oh sometimes
oh okay
okay
if my dad
these girls are like like you need to
use it for his money I'm like I'll just
go to my dad make Dad pay for her Poor
Dad Dad man stop giving up no no hey
he's had
he's had like what he'd rather have me
streeting look that's why I'm gonna tell
you if you have a daughter I always tell
men if you have a daughter pay for her
give her money
what I'm saying yeah
give her money hey Dad if you don't give
your daughter money she gonna find it
somewhere in some way you don't you
don't want her to get it
well I would I I like to think I
wouldn't but I always say all women have
or have thought about
going to get some money
no I've just been really privileged like
I don't most people don't grow up like I
did most people most people's parents
don't get water slides right yeah most
people don't do that yeah so you're in a
privileged position yeah but um yeah
most people aren't most people went
broke as hell
yeah so these girls out here in the
street and they serving you know men
like me you know you know we take we
take them out and show them a good time
see you have like sugar babies do I have
sugar babies I don't I don't call them
sugar babies we just call them Junior
College
but they're basically Sugar Babies
oh all women toward an Ascent are
transacting access to them how many do
you have
I don't keep them on I don't keep them
you know what I mean yeah yeah we we
have a we have we have freshman
orientation and sophomore graduation
every week
yeah every week There's a new
orientation coming in yeah so you know
what I mean it's like we don't wait by
semester we just wait for the week oh
yeah
she learning some stuff here yes we just
wait by the week every week you know a
girl goes broke
every week a girl gets evicted every
week a girl need a new pair of shoes
every week a girl needs something you
know she needs she every week the girl
goes hungry you know so at that
particular point you need a little bit
of you you need something other than
that Top Ramen you know what I mean and
then we we have a little fun and she
gets to fill up a refrigerator
yeah he came to the wrong place he
thought she was getting it she thought
she was going to get softball stuff at
that point
oh everybody there's no cash transaction
we don't deal in cash transactions sure
she gets a refrigerator
uh oh okay okay
I stunned her I stunned him silence yeah
okay
um
go in board you got some more about the
junior college
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible